I have genuinely good news for you from
the world of vaccines in Washington
State this is a loss for the anti-vaxxer
win for society and for children who
can't be vaccinated parents will no
longer be allowed to get their kids
vaccine exemptions in Washington State
for so-called personal or philosophical
reasons this is for the MMR vaccine if
their kids are going to go to daycare or
to school now this is good but it's also
a relatively small win and I'll explain
that in a second as you may know
Washington has some anti VAX elements
and that has led to a spike in measles
cases and the governor jay Inslee who's
also running for president says no more
personal or philosophical exemptions now
that's good
the problem is most of the exemptions
that people are getting in Washington
are religious religious exemptions those
are still available of course medical
exemptions are in place as well and
those are the only ones that we actually
need there may be medical reasons why
someone should not be vaccinated but as
as long as we don't do away with the
religious exemptions this is going to
remain a major problem and it's great
that right now you will no longer be
able to say I'm personally opposed to
vaccines I have philosophical objections
to vaccination but the overwhelming
majority of the non-medical exemptions
in Washington are religious so when you
get rid of personal and philosophical
it's very easy to say well what I mean
is it's my religion who can tell you
that it's not right and more importantly
something like 95 or 96 maybe even 98%
of the non-medical exemptions are
religious to begin with so we've got to
deal with this we should praise the fact
that Washington state is doing the right
thing here but you're not actually going
to deal with this for as long as someone
can say my religion tells me that I
should not get my kid vaccinated and of
course philosophical exemptions are
pretty ridiculous if you're an anti-tax
activist and you say I'm philosophically
against
taxation it's called the sovereign
citizen movement it doesn't work the
government says that that's not a good
explanation if you say you're
philosophically exempt from stop signs
stop signs are necessary and good for
society I don't think you're allowed to
get away with that this needs to be
considered the same way it's the right
decision that Washington is making but
we've got to get rid of those religious
exemptions germs don't care about your
philosophy they also don't care about
your religion they'll infect you or your
kid or the other person's kid who's
immunocompromised whether or not you are
religious or whether you have a
philosophical disagreement with
vaccinations and I get really bummed out
when I do a story like this because
every time I get emails from people who
say they love the show but I'm totally
wrong on vaccines and I should look at
Andrew Wakefield to work who of course
lost his medical license for his
deception on this issue or the medical
authorities say vaccines aren't safe or
autism all of this stuff it's truly and
deeply depressing to me that even people
in our audience who are mostly informed
about what's going on have fallen hook
line and sinker for the anti-vaccine
movement depressing but a small win if
nothing else in Washington State